they should call this movie Jeremy's
lookingglass I'm pretty sure I saw
exactly what I'm gonna be like when I'm
70 not sure how I feel about it but I
think it's important to accept the
reality of your situation dirty grandpa
so dirty grandpa is a comedy starring
Zac Efron and Robert DeNiro Zac Efron
he's a lawyer he's kind of a square and
he has to get his grandfather Robert De
Niro whose wife just died from point A
to point B it's a roadtrip movie with
Zac Efron and Robert De Niro and De Niro
is not what Zac Efron expected right out
the gate deniro's like let's go get some
[ __ ] now they're on the road trip okay
this movie is it's pretty simple I mean
simple and execution writing premise you
see right where the movies going
Zac Efron is marrying this girl she's
planning the wedding that she's a
complete bridezilla she's control freak
he should not be marrying her but
through this trip of depravity he's
gonna realize that there is fun to be
had in life and he should not be
marrying her up he's kind of like half
of Ed Helms from The Hangover story in
this movie except for the fact that Ed
Helms and a hangover wasn't the one
getting married if I did hangover didn't
do it first it's just this is a premise
that has been in movies like this for
years and this movie had simple ass
humor but it did have chuckles I mean
some of the writing I was like that's
the best joke you got some of it was
awkward some of it was uncomfortable
some of it the timing didn't land the
joke didn't land but there were moments
where it did land and I don't know if
the jokes got better or I just accepted
the reality of the situation that is
this movie it's a little shoddy first of
all Zac Efron continues to impress me as
a comedic actor he just does I never
really saw him as a comedic actor and
then he started doing comedies and I was
like hey you're not too bad it's like
Channing Tatum none of us knew that he
could do it and then he did it and we
were like hey that ain't too bad
keep doing that but where this movie
falls short is its wit there's nothing
in this movie that's really particularly
clever all the jokes are really simple I
mean there is a fair amount of what I
think is ad-libbing in this movie just
looks like actors are ad-libbing back
and forth sometimes at work this one
dude he's a drug dealer he actually did
really well there's this one girl she's
like the [ __ ] one that DeNiro is
trying to hook up with there is one
scene that actually made me laugh
because she kept going just monologuing
generally speaking she was just some
dirty [ __ ] he wanted to bang this old
dude and I was just like that's there's
really nothing clever you can spin out
of that granted the movies called dirty
grandpa not clever comedy this movie is
one of those movies where you get out of
and you're like
I had some fun with that movie I laughed
I chuckle it's not the smoothest movie
but you know it's a dirty-ass comedy
dirty ass comedy and you just kind of
accept it but then when you really have
to think about it because you have to do
a YouTube video reviewing the thing you
start thinking about it you're like yeah
it's not the best movie the movie does
feel like it goes on for a bit too long
the movie I don't even think it's two
hours long but it still does feel longer
than it needed to be so in the end I
liked Zac Efron I liked Zac Efron and
Robert De Niro is not like the greatest
Robert De Niro role ever but it's kind
of neat to see Robert De Niro be a seka
I don't know there's some morbid part in
my mind that likes that the pacing
sloppy and kind of [ __ ] sometimes so if
you enjoy a mindless ass raunch comedy
might have fun with this one if you
require some wit to your comedy you
might want to pass this one by in the
end I want to say dirty grandpa is
probably a great time if your trunk yeah
now it's a party [ __ ] and totally gonna
be like that little guy when I'm older
we're still your favorite raunch comedy
what is it whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more